now liz trusts and rishi sunak have
clashed once again in the latest debate
between the two hoping to be the next
conservative leader and prime minister
though the atmosphere and discussion was
more respectful than last night's tetchy
bbc debate there were exchanges about
the nhs and cost of living but the
program was cut short it was interrupted
at one point after a loud noise was
heard in the studio that the producer
said was caused by a medical issue
apparently involving the presenter kate
mccann formerly of sky news she
apparently fainted but is recovering
well we can just uh show you that the
moment in the debate liz trust had just
been asked a question and was just
starting to answer it when the noise was
heard
if he succeeds in ukraine he's not going
to stop that he's going to challenge the
freedom and democracy
well let's go live now to our chief
political correspondent uh john craig
well uh interrupted the debates i mean
first thoughts as liz trust showed there
um with
the presenter kate mccann who apparently
is is doing okay i can bring you a
statement dermot from news uk
excuse me um the statement says kate
mccann fainted on air tonight and
although she is fine the medical advice
was that we shouldn't continue with the
debate we apologize to our viewers and
listeners you saw the look of shock on
liz truss's face there and she obviously
moved forward
to try and help in any way that she
could that's kate mccann there in the
red outfit um kate mccann a former
colleague of ours here at sky news a
former before that a print journalist
with a number of uh national newspapers
including the sun um she left us to join
talk tv the news station
as their political editor
she was actually due to co-host that
debate with the sun's political editor
harry cole this morning he tested
positive for covid